[Music]
all right miss Walker never late
especially on my period I bet you
turrets like a wristwatch it's funny to
say that I've been told I have a uterus
a shape of a baseball glove clenching an
acorn anyway how's that application of
Cornell coming
well my parents love it but they love
everything I do I have my selfie right
there um what are you gonna cut the bull
sorry the bull honey my college
counselor okay a teacher of tomorrow oh
that's intense I bet your puffy little
nipples it's intense okay
puffy that is totally what they are I
have your file right here you know
what's in there phenomenal GPA test
scores through the roof you're a concert
level cellist and yet what did you write
your personal statement about on a
pledge that may Maresa and Kelly made
freshman year all right that hair
brained banana [ __ ] pact look at us
they made a pact to open our college
letter together what's gonna happen oh
boy even though we got the letters
months ago when our poor parents seemed
to put the deposits down to hold our
spots it's selfish it's a personal
statement personal okay you wrote about
two other people it's important to me
it's ridiculous should be ashamed
[Music]
you